can I kiss you can I kiss your bottom
lip but we're more than friends though
to you
we're on our way to 90th South and uh
then we're gonna do the go home thing
um
you're really fun to be on a date with
or whatever this is is this date this is
the dish right okay
it's amazing fun if you want to put like
a kiss in this area I'm okay with that
but she doesn't apparently okay
foreign
I don't think I can watch this [__]
shout out to skip amazing yeah this was
a really fun hangout date what is this
by the way was this a date
she's like uh this was amazing fantastic
a lovely evening
that was uh dinner but was it a date I
would say this may have been the most
fabulous after 10 p.m Excursion that
I've ever engaged but was this a date
oh
yeah like I feel like that's how the
attention in her face let's just like
get me out of this [__] and he
said
give me a kiss right here
hi I'm Skippy and I'm Tommy and Tommy
and I are friends
oh
oh oh
God Lee I don't know I don't know Skippy
was going on a date with American Sniper
the way she gave me my headshot
poof that my friends was a confirmed
killer oh yeah look at the smile she
said that with and the quickness with
she said right yeah fill in the blanks
oh she filled it in all right before you
[__] around and say something stupid I
don't like but we're more than friends
now
guys it ain't just what she said it's
how quickly she said it
and how much she didn't give up [__] how
he took it we have gone to what I call
Second and a half base because if third
base is oral we never got to that point
no
and why didn't we get to that point
because I stopped yeah and I'm
34 years old and I'm still a virgin and
you're 32. she's 32.
and are you still a virgin
no no but
see for me that it doesn't matter to me
that you're not a virgin because I don't
look at
us going on dates as a way for me to try
and have sex with you I look at us going
on dates because I really adore you and
I would love it if we could
be dating and then after dating be in
like a full-blown relationship that
would lead towards marriage and then
after we get married then I would love
to put my daddy Parts in your mommy
apart and and there you go that's the
reason why you're a virgin there's a lot
of people that have different reasons to
be a virgin hold up hold on see we're
here we're here you're gonna be all
right you're gonna be all right there's
a lot of people there's no reason why
people are virgins uh you know for
different reasons that you're good
you're good you're doing good you're
good you're doing good you're doing good
you're doing good huh
um but the fact that you call it mommy
parts and that
laughs
[Music]
yo I'm not even lying Loki
next I'm about to get in I want to say
that oh yeah you want this big in your
mommy Parts you want my daddy parts and
your mommy pipes that's why I see the
reaction I'm about to put that I'm about
to destroy your mommy Parts you guys
guys
all the people watching at home right
now who get some all right all you
virgins really got nobody in your life
just stay quiet we don't even for the
people who get some when you're about to
get on your partner I want you to say it
okay
and I'm about to enter your mommy Parts
a whole hour
can I have a kiss even though he kisses
can I kiss you can I kiss your bottom
lip
yeah I guess not disease no I I know
because the the upper one
I totally do is that okay yeah okay are
you gonna enjoy it
okay try it try as much enjoyment as you
can for me okay okay so you want me to
enjoy this try to okay okay
okay all right
that kind of tickled get it yeah okay
you're crazy you're crazy you're back to
crazy
you're back to crazy you're back back
right back that you were doing good and
then whoop right back you see trust your
instinct oh you're dead inside and you
killed Abba that's what you did the
craziness killed Abba and I said crazy
and I felt it and I was like oh yeah
when you said that oh there's a lot of
undertones in that [__] that sounds
weird like you know I mean it's all
weird yeah got flashbacks of people I
know that act like that and
um
my bad
uh hack number one that's the one
I'm not putting that on my face
oatmeal
that's nasty the number two what is what
is this green mud it's even worse than
oatmeal I'm not putting what what else
you got
fee man whoa hey yo listen all right
scratch all that I use th H Hanley he
don't know what to do and it's a bit
overwhelming I understand that I would
suggest you to buy the level one box
which comes with all the basics a daily
face watch which gets rid of all the
dirt and Grime on your face then got it
two times per week exfoliating scrub to
get rid of all the dead skin cells and
an AM moisturizer with SPF 20 because we
all need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the Sun and they're going
to be able to give you all the
instruction in order for you to have a
good skin care for you to be looking all
Flawless yeah because that's your money
maker that's the first thing that people
see when they see you your face that's
right and you got to take care of it if
you click on the link below you will not
only save 30 off your first box but you
will also receive a gift get it it's
uncomplicated skin care routine for men
that's what I use look at this flower
dollars that's just nice compared to
this morning you could do a before and
after
but not until then
oh my gosh this is the most
amazing girl I've ever met though like
you uh
you genuinely are one of my favorite
people that I've ever known my entire
life and
the hurdle in our relationship is
you are dating other guys
yeah of course
another hurdle in her y'all relationship
is that she thinks you're a friend
because she's not interested not that
she's dating other dudes because if
she's dating another Deuces dating you
she really liked you she would choose
you or the other guys but she don't want
to because you ain't [__] I just want to
appreciate guys the things that Skippy's
are saying aren't necessarily not
beautiful minus the Monty Parson they
actually are is that when they come from
him they mean nothing no because the
same way guys if a [__] came up to you
and said yo you want this brother you
would be like brother get that [__] out
of here when a woman that you're
actually interested in you got on some
dates offers to sleep that's exciting
you're sexy right because you know that
there was a build up process that this
was earned through actual interaction
and who you are and not just a virtue of
like someone's job or some patheticness
of like
I need some crack [__] me you know I
mean there's nothing like that so that's
what Skippy is I need some crack some
[__] crack
yeah yeah it'll be like that's what
Skippy is like he's like
you know some people still like that
because they're a little [__] up but
like they want AIDS or whatever but
that's what Skippy is he's a crackhead
to women yeah he's not unappealing like
hey hi hi hi hi Joshua yo knowing you
super cool man you're cool man you're
really cool like I really like you yeah
and everything and stuff drop some more
of that crack I know that's Skippy
that's him and don't say the most
extreme stuff doesn't get to get shoes
like buddy you're the most amazing
person
sorry but you tweaking
skippiest week you're one of the my
favorite person I've ever met like once
or twice
I didn't actually do anything amazing
you're just so [__] pathetic and
you've never managed to bond with people
that the minimum amount I showed you you
went crazy it's not about me it's about
the fact that you're a loser that's what
it's about
and yeah I'm trying to be exclusive
yeah I don't I I I I don't want to be
exclusive
I can't
or
maybe she's really out here in these
streets [__] Hey listen when a dude's
beating her back out and giving that
good D I bet you anything she done to be
exclusive hey man you know what someone
put me on this not long ago she said
let's have when you out here you have to
know there's different types of dicks I
was like what that's gay don't tell me
that she's like no you want to hear this
there's some men who got boyfriend dick
I was like what's that
he's like
because the kind of penis that you
definitely want to make your boyfriend
because it's that consistently good what
I'm trying to say guys is
if you got that they're not trying to go
left right and Center because when we're
going to find something that's really
good they want to go there consistently
because going out with random dudes
oftentimes ends up in bad sex so if you
got it good
you got that boyfriend and Lace am I
live is there such a thing as a
boyfriend D yeah let me know in the
comments yeah
I heard I don't know there's 711d
convenience store
some of y'all got that convenience store
you were to like a butterfly that has
supersonic speed and cannot be caught
yeah I'm a butterfly
you're like Sonic the the Hedgehog and a
butterfly if they made it
[Music]
[Applause]
pounce yeah
because you are you ready
you're the runway non-bride yeah yeah
yeah I won't commit
which is very difficult to ever lose my
virginity no no no no no no no Mama no
no no no you can't tell a crackhead that
no no you can't tell a crackhead you got
a crack
you can't tell a crackhead you got crack
and expect them to leave you alone the
thing that happened is this mama is he
paying for the days no they both pay
anything
I don't know I don't know if he's paying
for holidays I don't know because you're
not she's not going there hey man listen
I think she's just a flirty person or
whatever yeah but I don't just want to
lose my virginity for the sake of that I
want to lose it to you because I adore
you and I feel that very strong L word
towards you
I know
okay
she was a very strong L word towards you
you can't say L word you can't say
oh my God you know what I'm gonna get it
it's like when a girl pulls away
sometimes guys think the best thing to
do is to rush head forced it's like no
they pulling away sometimes you got to
give them that space to make them
realize they need you but the more you
try to hold on and grab on and say
you're not going anywhere I love you and
all this other stuff the more they
become disgusted and revolted by you
because it seems like you're desperate
sometimes you gotta just give them the
space
let them come back on their own time you
let him know it's an open space but him
doing this desperate stuff when she's
already said repeatedly she's not she's
becoming less interested in him by the
second
all right that's all I can watch bro I
can't um
hey man the reason why I play these
videos if you guys aren't watching if
you see any of this behavior in
yourselves hopefully you learn it don't
repeat it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
uh anything you want to say no I don't
think so